en este vídeo quiero dar un
entendimiento sobre las diferentes sobre
los diferentes participantes que emiten
y procesan tus tarjetas de crédito
entonces iniciamos con los procesadores
aquí lo voy a escribir procesadores
procesadores y podrías decir que que la
red o los procesadores son personas que
mantienen las redes de tarjetas de
crédito ejemplos de estos son visa
mastercard american expres también
american express discover también sería
otra y lo que hacen es mantener redes de
información tecnológica y también
políticas que conectan a los bancos
aunque no nos complicaríamos tanto la
existencia en este vídeo supongamos que
está aquí es la red uno este círculo
quizás sea visa visa y acá está la red 2
aquí supongamos que es master card y
bueno por ahora son simples círculos
pero ya verás cómo se forman redes
mientras avanza el vídeo entonces
supongamos que yo soy un banco un banco
y me voy a nombrar
bankoa aquí estoy yo es mi banco bueno
soy el banco
yo pienso bueno sabes que sería bueno
que yo para mi negocio que yo emite una
tarjeta de crédito podría extender
crédito a mis clientes me pagarían
intereses cobraría una cuota es un buen
negocio para mi banco entonces voy con
vice le pregunto si puedo ser yo miembro
de su red vice tiene algunas políticas y
bueno si eres un banco legítimo y estás
de acuerdo con las políticas te harás
miembro de esa red así que lo hago me
uno a esta red y claro yo no soy la
única el único miembro de este de esta
red así que aquí hay otro miembro
digamos el miembro ve acá está el
miembro se y acá está otro miembro de
donde también cada uno son redes
entonces tienen otros bancos como
miembros y aquí está la red de
mastercard entonces supongamos que yo
soy una cliente del banco y quiero una
tarjeta de crédito porque no me gusta
cargar con dinero así que me dicen muy
bien chica del vídeo es totalmente
conveniente para ti una tarjeta de
crédito y me la emiten así que esta es
mi tarjeta de crédito
supongo todo el mundo ha visto tarjetas
de crédito
dicen bueno esto diría banco a muy
grande con letras grandes arriba
entonces dirá banco hay también tendrá
un número de tarjeta de crédito algo así
raro y bueno un número gigante también
tendrá mi nombre de chica del vídeo y
también algún tipo de fecha de
expiración y en la parte inferior
derecha dirán a qué red pertenezco en
esta ocasión sería visa una tarjeta de
emitida aquí diría mastercard o si fuera
americanexpress diría american expres
siempre hay justo en la parte inferior
derecha entonces bueno ya tengo una
tarjeta de crédito creo que todo el
mundo tenemos un sentido de lo que es yo
lo puedo usar y crear un balance en el
futuro puedo pagar ese balance a este
banco o puedo cargar con un balance y me
cobrarán intereses pero por lo general
son intereses muy altos y yo lo quiero
pagar rápidamente pero cómo funciona
realmente esto en un contexto de red
digamos que yo voy a la tienda local lo
voy a dibujar en naranja digamos que yo
voy a esta tienda
llamémosle tiendas y compro mil pesos de
mandado y yo quiero pagar con mi recién
emitida tarjeta así que lo voy a
escribir aquí para que quede más
sería aquí el banco es el emisor voy a
la tienda y digo yo quiero pagar con mi
tarjeta de crédito y si en esa tienda
aceptan tarjetas de crédito ellos deben
tener alguna relación con algún otro
banco deben de alguna manera estar
conectados a esta red de visas para que
ellos puedan aceptar una tarjeta de
visas entonces digamos que si están
relacionados con el banco ve con este
banco ve este sería un banco minorista
comúnmente llamado banco adquirente y es
llamado así porque va a cada uno de los
mercados y bueno está te digo por qué se
llama así lo pongo aquí es adquirente se
le llama adquirente porque él es el que
sale y va con cada uno de los
comerciantes y les dice oye tú solamente
aceptas efectivo solamente aceptas a
american express no sería bueno que
también aceptará esa visa o mastercard
de esa manera vas a abrir tu mercado a
más clientes será más conveniente para
tus clientes y cada vez que se hace una
transacción pues tomamos un porcentaje
de esta transacción entonces salen y
adquieren algunos minoristas esta fue la
tienda ge y también después quizás vaya
a otra
s luego otra tienda que también son
diferentes minoristas que um de repente
aceptarán a visa porque su banco es un
miembro de la red de visa aunque también
pudo haber sido miembro de american
express o de mastercard aquí no importa
porque bueno la idea la idea se conserva
este su procesador y está de su red
entonces bueno supongamos que en este
caso la tienda g en este contexto acepta
a visa así que yo le doy mi tarjeta de
visa y el primer proceso se llama
autorización autorización y lo que hace
es asegurarse de que yo tenga el dinero
que esta tarjeta sea válida para comprar
los mil pesos de demandado que quiero
comprar entonces cuando yo pasé la
tarjeta mandará un mensaje de esa
pequeña unidad de venta al banco
adquirente luego la mandará a visa así
que visa dirá o esa tarjeta del banco va
y dará el número al banco a en su propio
número propietario y el banco a mirar a
los datos y dirá o si en efecto es esta
chica tiene dos mil pesos
crédito y no los ha usado yo autorizo la
transacción y ese mensaje regresa por la
red al banco ven y bueno al fin quedamos
autorizados
luego la transacción sigue hacia
adelante y eventualmente como tú puedes
imaginar no solamente se autoriza una
transacción y yo salgo con mi mandado
muy campante en algún punto la tienda
que va a querer obtener su dinero por
darme el mandado él tiene la expectativa
de recibir sus mil pesos y esos mil
pesos los obtendrá del banco ah y aunque
no obtendrá los mil pesos completos
porque obviamente cada uno de estos
participantes están brindando un
servicio éste está metido en la red y
está ofreciendo crédito ofreciendo
ofreciendo crédito mientras que el
procesador de la red está ofreciendo su
red y existen claro que si existen otros
servicios que pueden brindar otros
mecanismos de seguridad si dicen o esta
chica vive en el distrito federal pero
aún de repente está comprando mil pesos
demandado en
guadalajara y mérida algo que parece
sospechoso y regular entonces manda en
algún tipo de alerta ahora bien todos
están brindando un servicio por ejemplo
esta tienda quizás está brindando las
terminales de venta y así todas brindan
servicios entonces todos van a obtener
algún tipo de corte así que por ejemplo
de los mil pesos que yo que yo compré en
que yo compré así que pongo aquí compra
de mil pesos habrá que dar el 2% aunque
no siempre es el 2% yo solamente digo
ese porcentaje por lanzar un número
aunque en el caso no es muy muy lejano
al caso real entonces de los mil pesos
que yo puedo obtener por la compra debe
pagar en este caso lo que son lo que es
el 2% así que pagó 20 pesos 2 por ciento
de mil pesos son 20 pesos así que debo
pagar un descuento de 20 pesos pongo
aquí 20 pesos en tasa de descuento
de pesos en tasa de descuento y se lo
pago al banco adquirente así que aquí lo
pongo pagado al banco adquirente y tú
dirás guau el banco adquirente obtiene
el 2% de las transacciones de ellos pero
claro tendrá que repartirlo con los
otros de acá y de hecho la mayor
cantidad la obtiene en el banco a así
que de estos 20 pesos vamos a repartir
los 20 pesos el banco a obtendrán
digamos que 17 pesos y repito no es tan
distinto a lo que en realidad se cobra
aunque claro depende de los bancos la
red y todo quizás las redes también sus
tasas de vez en cuando
así que 17 pesos 17 pesos van al banco y
ahora bien el banco emisor ahora que yo
ya tengo mi balance de crédito ya podrá
cobrar intereses y también va a obtener
los 17 pesos por esa transacción esos 17
pesos de los 20 pesos eso tiene un
nombre se le llama comisión
interbancaria y la comisión ínter banca
haría generalmente se establece por las
redes aunque las redes no compartan esa
comisión ellos simplemente dicen lo
siguiente nuestra comisión interbancaria
estándar es el 10% de transacción más no
sé qué te gustaría a 10 centavos y eso
es lo que el banco ve pagará al banco a
así que esencialmente al banco a se le
corta de la tasa de descuento de los 20
pesos que éste le cobra a éste y ahora
bien las redes hacen dinero en distintas
maneras pero por lo general hacen dinero
de cada transacción también de ahí hacen
dinero en este ejemplo es un peso esto
va hacia el procesador esto va al
procesador así que cada vez que tú haces
una transacción el procesador obtiene
una fracción de tu compra y bueno veamos
este este día acá el banco ve bueno pues
entonces serían 17 18 se va a quedar con
dos pesos 2 pesos de los 20 pesos y
bueno cuando toda la transacción se
resuelva y cada quien obtenga
dinero que debe obtener este banco va a
mandar al banco de liquidación de visa
los mil pesos menos los diecisiete pesos
que obtuvo por esa comisión
interbancaria así que le mandara a visa
lo que son 983 pesos eso es lo que visa
obtendrá y visa obtiene un peso de eso y
manda el resto al banco adquisitivo así
que para acá manda lo que son 982 pesos
luego el banco adquisitivo se queda con
dos pesos y manda al minorista 980 pesos
y bueno mis números no son exactos sólo
quiero darte la idea así que para que
este minorista puede usar toda esta
infraestructura tuvo que pagar el 2% de
esa transacción aunque no siempre será
el 2% pero es para darte la idea y bueno
hay que recordar este minorista se
beneficia porque tiene acceso a una red
y eso es conveniente para los clientes
que está obteniendo un pago por cada
minorista y entre más minoristas tenga
más cortes de transacción va a obtener
mientras que visa tiene un pequeño
corte de muchas muchas demasiadas
transacciones y así es como gana dinero
y bueno claro también debe usar algo de
ese dinero para mantener toda esta
infraestructura luego el banco hará ese
intercambio de comisión que fue la mayor
parte de la tasa de descuento el cual
cabe mencionar que nada se relaciona con
la tasa de fondos de la reserva federal
y claro ellos me dieron crédito así que
de los mil pesos que tal vez no se
paguen de inmediato tal vez me cobren el
15 o el 20 por ciento anualizados un
porcentaje de tasa anualizada de interés
de ese dinero y bueno también claro hay
algunos balances mínimos que hay que
pagar